all right joining us now for the
exclusive interview he's the former
mayor in New York City he is the current
president of attorney for the president
president Trump Rudy Giuliani is with us
all right nice to be back Sean wow we've
we've been through a lot together I was
here when you were mayor of course yeah
and the city is still benefiting from
your anger so much that's it so kind
just why don't we start as simple could
give us the status of the special
council and what's going on with the
president well the special council would
like to interview the president there's
no secret about that every lawyer in
America thinks he shouldn't be we
meeting myself and Jay Sekulow and the
raskins and all the people involved in
the investigation and now our new
colleague Emmitt we're going to have to
decide
probably it falls more on us because
he's on the government side whether the
president should granted in the view
here's what it's all about it's real
simple and American people can follow
this along with me
are they objective are they well right
now a lot of things point in the in the
direction of they made up their mind
that Comey is telling the truth and not
the president when you look at those
questions about what does the president
think what does the president feel what
does the president really desire those
are all questions intended to trap him
in some way in contradictory what is in
fact a very very solid explanation of
what happened
he fired Comey because Comey would not
among other things say that he wasn't
they targeted the investigation he's
entitled to that Hillary Clinton got
that and she he couldn't get that so he
fired him
and he said I'm free of this guy and he
went on Lester Holt Lester Holt
interview was as good as anybody could
do better than I think any of the people
around MOA could have done and Lester
Holt asked him why'd you do it he said I
did it because I felt that I had to
explain to the American people their
president was not the target of the
investigation and even Jake Tapper
pushed him like really hard talk about
call me call me had no answer for why he
didn't say this even though he had done
the same thing
hilary so you can't blame the president
for feeling i am not being treated the
same way they were I mean I don't expect
that we're gonna have an interview with
it with the exoneree exonerating
rhetoric already written like we had
well I have a lot of questions for you I
can't I would like to get one not under
oath I'd wanted a videotaped and I'm not
video taped with audio tapes okay I want
to make sure they don't misrepresent his
answers but this is an outrageous
miscarriage of justice please consider
whether you're a Republican or a
Democrat whether you hate President
Trump or you love them like we do or
like I do I think people know I'm pretty
I think the secret's out of the be okay
let you off the hook
full disclosure now everything Rudy
Giuliani and I once had a meal together
okay I don't remember who paid so you
can't possibly
you can't possibly not feel as a citizen
of the world that is his negotiations
with North Korea a much more significant
than this totally garbage investigation
you know let me let me ask you first
about the legal team Ty Cobb John Dowd
they're out my understanding is Ty Cobb
had been saying for some time he was
gonna retire well it's not what happened
ty has been enormous ly helpful
he certainly helped me with my
orientation we wouldn't be where we are
today which is in a very strong position
if it wasn't for him and John John has
been my friend and colleague for 35
years I have nothing but the utmost
respect for John Dowd he had the right
instincts about this which is you're
gonna get him to testify over my dead
body because you're trying to trap him
he had those instincts way back when it
was harder to see those so all that work
didn't go for nothing we got it all Jay
has been the the rock he's been Jay
Sekulow
a psycho he's been through this comply
couldn't do it without Jay and I think I
offer what I offer this is something
unique I'm a lawyer who knows the
criminal justice system as well as
anybody in America I'm also a very good
friend of Donald Trump and I think I
have the
spective Muller the FBI the Justice
Department you should Jeff Sessions was
my colleague not just in the campaign
but back in 1981 when he was US Attorney
in Alabama I don't think I'm going to
that they know the decision I make is
going to be in the best interest not
just to my client for the United States
if they're objective we can work
something out if they're not then we
have to shake hands and basically go
into a litigation over do they have the
power to subpoena and I think they lost
that power this is a completely tainted
investigation explain well you have an
investigation in which Muller is
selected the day after he's turned down
for FBI director why Rosenstein who was
there when Muller was turned down there
are thousands of people that could have
been selected for that job also a friend
of James Comey and James Comey seems to
be they're there they're there their
core of their investigation he's telling
the truth the president isn't I know
James Comey I know the president sorry
Jim you're a liar
a disgraceful liar every FBI agent in
America has his head down because he you
it would have been good for God if God
had kept you out of being a head of the
FBI explain where he lied well they lied
he lied about his conversation with
McCabe he knew all the McCabe's
conflicts McCabe should testify against
him he lied about his conversation with
the president he only told the truth
when the president said I'm a we know
Donald I'm sorry mr. president he was
Donald before he lied about the fact
that they talked about whether the
president was a subject or a target then
he immediately changed it it's one lie
after another rod Rosenstein everybody
forgets when he wrote that that
recommendation to fire Comey he said
that the FBI cannot be reestablished if
he stayed at the hell yeah why because
he's a liar
his conduct of the Hillary Clinton
investigation was a total disgrace
if Hillary couldn't have been elected
president he wouldn't have lasted past
day one we know she would have fired him
I don't think she'd even deny that today
she was right
we should have fired him and when I say
we I mean the collective we hear day one
let let's talk about let me say one
other thing yes sir
this is our best president in my memory
in two years
even even my hero Ronald Reagan he
straightened the economy out the way
President Trump did but he didn't get
this far ahead on foreign policy as fast
as President Trump has look at what's
going on with North Korea I've told the
president you're gonna get the Nobel
Peace Prize and then my proudest moment
is when you tell them to shove it sorry
by the way no no this is cable you're
good here
you said about the let's talk about the
leak questions you know I mean I have
him here in front of me I mean what's in
your thoughts what did you think about
call me what did you think about
sessions what a college economy should
be prosecuted for leaking confidential
FBI information when he leaked his
report intended to develop a special
prosecutor for the President of the
United States I have never ever turned
over a dock you know me Sean
we want to US Attorney I a lot of
allegations to my mop never leaked a
damn thing I would have considered
resigning if I ever did that or if one
of my assistants did it to the FBI leak
to the SEC leak I'm sorry guys you did
let me ask you this there is so many
lawyers that I respect that you know and
respect Alan Dershowitz Jodha Gentiles
these are heavy hitters our own Gregg
Jared has so long my friends they the
president should never spend a minute
you said it would be narrow and focused
today and you said no more than two or
three hours do you believe Robert Muller
is setting a perjury trap for Donald
Trump well I have to remain and J and
our team has to remain open-minded about
this because even though you might not
see a clear
Avenue to quickly resolving this for the
American people we may and we know that
our president we know that our president
will seek a resolution that gets him a
clear path to getting it resolved so I
would I would say right now the odds are
he wouldn't be interviewed but I don't
cause my mind to it I when we're talking
about what I mean because this is really
important because they're talking about
a subpoena and the subpoena that means
that the President of the United States
I always said that they should have the
Hilary standard and the Hilary standard
is really simple not under oath not well
wait a minute and and you have a guy
that hates Hillary and loves Donald
Trump during the interview that would be
the hillary standard right well we're
not gonna get that could we accept
something less than that yes could we
accept a situation in which they're
telling us basically we believe Comey
who is now a pathological liar as
opposed to Donald Trump then the answer
to that is no all right I have been
probably the most outspoken loudest
critic in the country besides the
president about robert muller and a team
of democratic donors no republicans
people say well he's a republican and is
a veteran okay i applaud him for serving
his country I mean that Andrew Weissman
tens of thousands of people lost their
job mr. mayor at Enron tens of thousands
an I know decision against against
Andrew Weissman who gets 904 merrill
executives in jail for a year overturned
by Fifth Circuit Court of Appeals and he
was excoriated twice for withholding
exculpatory evidence that appointment
alone sir tells me that this is a biased
bum let me give you two different views
of Bob for what do I know of Bob that I
could testify to under oath a patriot an
extraordinarily good man served his
country serve this country did a good
job with the FBI I don't think he would
be affected by malice or prejudice
however I don't have an explanation for
the people that he hired not all of them
I've dealt with him very briefly I think
they're very professional Iseman I
didn't deal with why so much quarrels
very good men disturbed by his record
yeah yeah but you know he would probably
be disturbed by mine so I I have an open
mind about about Bob I don't about call
me I've closed my mind about call me I
know call me much better I have the
indignity of fortunately of having hired
him for his first big job and I'm
embarrassed that I hired him we go to a
Tweep of the president this isn't so
many tweeted John Dowd this isn't some
game you're screwing the work of the
President of the United States of
America John Dowd 2018 North Korea China
the Middle East so much more there is
not much time to be thinking about this
especially since there's no Russia
collusion mr. mayor it's been going on
how many congressional investigations
this has been going on now almost a full
year there's no evidence of Trump Russia
collusion how did we end up from there
to stormy Daniels because this is I
think this is being done behind molars
back in a sense because they come to him
with all kinds of it doesn't read a
newspaper
yeah self-serving statements this has
become a witch-hunt like the president
said and if you look at those questions
that are being asked their trap
questions a first-year prosecutor would
do better than that
so he's in very good hands now I don't
just mean me I mean Jay and the whole
team and Ty gets a great deal of credit
for all this because he orchestrated it
I'm looking forward to working with
Emmett who handled the Clinton very
situation that attorney and I came in
Bush and then Bush so this is not a
political guy he said if they're
objective meaning Muller and his team
more likely will be willing to cooperate
the lust of then we would be foolish to
do that you said you also said there'll
be a decision in just a couple of weeks
you got well I can't imagine it's gonna
take much longer it's coming to it
coming to a head right now and there's
not much more to think about if they can
if they can if they can get us in a
position where we can recommend to the
president
in me you know President Trump of course
you know he wants to be interviewed
right mm-hmm I do if he doesn't it's
gonna be because Jay and I and and and
others say no and at the raskins and we
would stand up there and say you look
we're lawyers you got to listen to it
mr. president
listen I think I'm I think I'm there
because I'm his friend well I think your
background as an attorney all the years
of the mayor the president and I have
agree with the president's statement and
I have been very open and nested saying
this that this is a setup that this is a
subpoena this is a perjury trap and
let's walk through what if they issue a
subpoena what if they tell that if he
does decide not to talk they send him
before a grand jury because it becomes
tricky as Alan Dershowitz is described
on this show if the president pleads the
fifth which he doesn't want to do he
said he doesn't want to do then they
give him immunity then what okay so
let's take let's look at that I think
Alan kind of point is that a bit last
night on your show but not in detail if
they issue a subpoena that will be that
will be unprecedented in the sense that
it's pretty clear that a president can't
be subpoenaed to a criminal proceeding
about him now why is that and
unfortunately or maybe unfortunately we
have the real life circumstance going on
that the founding fathers thought about
which is a president cannot be
distracted by a criminal investigation
you can always prosecute them after they
can get him when he leaves the White
House
you could always prosecute a master but
we I could not it if most said to me
tomorrow
bring him in two hours it's like you
want no questions that you don't want
and we're pretty much ready to clear I
could not go to the president United
States and say take two days off to get
ready for that and screw the whole thing
with North Korea I how can any American
do that he's our president he is going
to negotiate I believe
a non-nuclear situation on the Korean
Dean thanks a lot nobody thought about
here all right and you're gonna
interfere with that that's why the
founding fathers created this immunity
from prosecution and subpoena now if
it's a civil case Hunton submitted
because of the civil case why not
written answers to a proffer which
Ronald what's wrong with Ronald Reagan
did why not that because they did they
said no to that they said no to that and
that so they wanted then so the
president says that they're gonna what
at this point I'm not sure I'd give him
written answers because they're gonna
try to contradict them I believe I
believe that attorney General Sessions
my good friend and Rosenstein who I
don't know I believe they should in the
interest of justice in this
investigation there's been too much
government misconduct the crimes now
have all been committed by the
government and their agents the lies by
Comey I'm gonna go through this in a
minute hold on
it's terrible what are the parameters
that you would insist on for any
interview with Muller beyond two to
three hours narrowing the scope never
beyond two or three hours would never
happen I'm not gonna have my client my
president my friend and a president has
achieved more in a year and a half
against all odds than anyone had a right
to expect I'm not gonna let him be
treated worse than Bill Clinton who
definitely was a liar under oath I'm not
gonna let it be true
he's being treated much worse than
Hillary Clinton who had no right to any
of that stuff so I'm not gonna let him
be treated worse than Hillary Clinton
and I think Jay and I will insist that
they're gonna have to treat him the same
way as Clinton two and a half hours we
end we walk out give us your questions
in advance he's ready to I know and I
you know if we weren't careful lawyers
we just let him go I mean he's he's
about the my remember the debates that I
prepared him for in part with Chris
Christie but that was a Kellyanne cause
a real story behind that I bet oh wow
but did he execute he did oh I saw you
after every debate you did and he got
better and better